at this graph question okay now
for starters we already know at least
most of us already knew what a log curve
basically looks like okay it's this guy
i'm so happy i know i'm glad you know it
okay so this is our basic
log graph there's no details on here
this could be log base two could be log
base e i don't know
any other details okay
uh that's an arrow that's an error well
i hope you know that it's an error
because the log curve just goes forever
yeah
okay so i need to think about how do i
take this basic
log curve and adjust it to take
into account the fact that there's this
x1 and there's also this eight these are
the two important things
okay max okay very good so the x plus
one
tells me that the transformation is i
shift
one unit to the left
translation is the fancy word but i
think we're all happy to call it a shift
you know what that means okay so this is
a shift one
unit left is that okay
now that base e now i want you to have a
look at your graph because i saw very
few people who actually did this
i want you to have a look at my graph
over here which i've already drawn for
you
i want you to tell me how can you tell
that my graph
is a base e graph as opposed to like
base two
base three base four any other base
parameters
very good so i've got a point for scale
now i had a look around a lot of you
you were not you didn't provide me a
point for scale so that was kind of a
problem
your graph could have just as easily had
some different base and would still look
exactly like yours okay so let's let's
now try to work this out
the first thing i'm going to do is you
can see unlike my normal log curve
you can see i'm drawing a bit of extra
space over here
yeah because i'm accounting for this
shift everything goes one unit to the
left
okay so very good let's start with the
asymptote that's good spot usually i
have an
asymptote where what's the equation of
the asymptote
x equals zero thank you as opposed to
say y equals zero which the exponential
curve would have that's a horizontal
line
so if my asymptotes usually x equals
zero
but i've said we're shifting one unit to
the left where is it now
you have to make it negative x equals
negative one fantastic so let's go ahead
and let's draw that right if you didn't
get this
one hundred percent
that's not a bad way to think about it
but the danger is
that you don't always like having it
equal zero is not always
the right way to go about it because
there might be for example
if i gave you something like this
something like that okay um this is more
complicated than just like oh it's just
gone this way or that way um you'd have
to think about yeah those things equal
zero give you asymptotes
but on a log curve it does something
else okay so it's not a bad rule of
thumb but
i think this is a more helpful way of
thinking about it this is where my
asymptote usually is and i'm shifting it
okay what else do you normally know
about the log curve that we can also
shift
over to the left and you take as tavares
or in your graph there's an important
point that you can put on there
yeah cool what do we call that the point
where it goes through it has a name
uh well it will be the origin but the
name of that point is the intercept
right
now it's going to go through the origin
because where did it go before
max
yeah one comma zero right so nothing's
happened to the vertical but this guy
has moved one unit that way okay so
that's where i'm gonna pass through so
you can see that's how i get
this same basic shape okay so that's at
zero
asymptote check intercept checked yes
okay all right now i want you all to
know right
this graph here which a lot of you have
drawn
this could be log base two of x plus one
you can put into decimals or log base
four yeah i need something to give me a
sense of the scale
vertically and horizontally right so
therefore you've got to provide a point
now
have a think normally right let's
suppose i was
picking something like log base 2 of x
this is the normal graph
right the way to know how you work out a
good spot on it is you think about the
base
down here okay so a good spot for this
graph would be like two or four or eight
right because they're all powers of
two right um in this case the spot i
would actually pick would be the first
one
which would be two comma one okay
but i've got a base of e for this graph
i'm supposed to draw
so for this i would think about what
happens if i put a
in here or something like that okay max
what are you thinking
very good so if i had log base e
of e right that's one that's like e to
the power of one gives you e
right that's the way a log equation
works the only snag is
um i had to do this
had to do this shift one unit to the
left yeah
so instead of putting e in there well to
get in there i've got to put and you can
see the point that i've chosen right
e i'll put it in red e take away one
do you see how that works okay well
let's let's just evaluate it right if i
put in
x equals e take away 1 then you
have to add 1 to it because that's what
the equation of the graph is so e
take away 1 plus 1 gives you what
a minus one plus one will give you e
right e take away one plus one
do you agree with that gives you e and
that's what gives you this
one on the right hand side that you're
after okay so that is how i chose
my point for scale which you really
really should put the they didn't tell
you
but that's um that is a bit sneaky
well would you lose a mark answer
i can't tell what your graph is until
that point is there
right if this graph had a different base
it could still look like that except it
just wouldn't go through that point
okay so would you lose the mark i think
it's pretty plausible
okay yeah make sense